foreign
holding the line on the steps of
Congress and with thousands beyond the
supporters of an ousted president who
won't accept he lost
ever since the election last October
there was a concern that this would
unfold and so it has at Congress that
the Supreme Court and at the
presidential Palace hundreds were moving
in
the early moments of this attempt to
overthrow the government seemed to
unfold with Little Resistance from the
security forces
but the tip of the spear protesters made
it inside Congress into the chamber
scenes reminiscent of America's
Democratic test the January the sixth
protest in Washington DC here though
there were no politicians inside at the
time still they destroyed the place this
room used for meetings with visiting
heads of state ransacked
by Nightfall as the police were
regaining control authorities said 400
people had been arrested
the election was in October the
far-right president Yaya bolsonaro
ousted by his left-wing opponent Lula de
Silva bolsonaro didn't turn up he's in
Florida instead and has calls from U.S
politicians came for him to be kicked
out he tweeted peaceful demonstrations
within the law are part of democracy
however attacks and invasions of public
buildings has happened today just like
those committed by the left in 2013 and
2017 escaped the rule of law
president Lula was not in Brasilia but
was on the airwaves swiftly
I wanted to tell you that the people who
did this will be found and they will be
punished we are going to find the
financiers and they will all pay with
the full force of the law for this
irresponsible undemocratic gesture this
gesture of vandals and fascists
but president Lula knows the challenge
bolsonaro always said that if he was
removed from Power violence would follow
he flirted with his extreme base he
stoked evidence-free claims of electoral
fraud Brazil's Democratic fragility is
now playing out at its political heart
this is the first big test for president
Lula Mark Stone Sky News
[Music]